[Music]
ufos
ufo ufos okay let's talk about them
i love them yeah we've been talking a
lot about aliens and how there's like a
lot of like
people saying that they confirm them
people in government all that stuff
right well
there is this video that
has gone pretty viral recently and it's
a video of an
airplane passenger filming outside their
window
while they're on an airplane and they're
about to land
in switzerland so this is like a
commercial flight a commercial flight
yes
a commercial flight a singapore's
airline flight
and they have really good business
classes
i love singapore yeah they're the best
they're really good um so then this
passenger
was filming outside their window because
you know just the landscapes so pretty
and all this stuff
everyone films the landing yeah yeah and
that's when the pilot
started making some announcements
we have a ufo uh no oh
here we go
on the floor bend over place your face
i'll just try to get them to brace for
impact
i was clearly now bracing
this guy doesn't give me a shot oh did
you see that
yeah yeah i missed it i missed it look
at this replay replay because the
position he was describing it sounds
like
uh embracing for impact position
holy [ __ ] he said put your face look at
this
that is crazy what is that i mean
it's a ufo man that's literally what a
ufo is we don't know what
unidentified flying objects that's a
flying burrito frisbee
no it's a long one though high altitude
frisbee [ __ ] that's crazy
that [ __ ] bananas how big do you
think that thing is in real life
i don't know but they were saying they
were saying that a pilot
cannot see a drone no you can't
they'll just smash into it yeah exactly
lined too fast exactly so then
the fact that this pilot saw this object
and told people to start bracing
or move out of it no and then so yeah
the pilot was doing like a maneuver
to avoid this ufo like that's [ __ ]
crazy so the ufo went under
yeah it looks like it went under like
big or something or some sort of size if
he's like okay
i need to dodge it or we need a brace
for impact in case it crashes into us
i see that speed i want to see that is
insane
what is that well i don't know how far
away it is relative to the to the
yeah exactly it's moving so fast it's
moving super fast
oh i was thinking it wasn't moving fast
because the plane itself is moving
really fast
because then if we could see it i assume
it's just staying still yeah and then
the plane flew by it
yeah unless it's like further away than
it was because if it's going like this
it would be way fast it'd be really hard
to catch so
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah kudos to the
pilot for being able to even see it
exactly i have a friend he's a uh he
just got his pilot's license and he was
saying you know when you
when you're flying into airspace the
reason why they have those air
uh traffic controllers is none of the
planes can even see each other
so if you imagine like if you're on the
intersection right there's like four-way
intersection everyone is about to meet
at the middle waiting for red light or
green light
in the air it's way more than four-way
intersection it's more like
eight-way intersection with multiple
levels people descending or landing
so everyone is trusting the air traffic
controller
to kind of navigate and tell them like
where to go the
the guy that's there the guy the guy
that's on the uh in the tower
at the bottom that's what my brother
does he's an air traffic so the guy in
the tower is responsible for
hearing how fast this person is
approaching in what direction
and then telling the guy okay you got to
make a u-turn you got to turn around and
that's why it's like the most stressful
job
i've heard is a very stressful job
because you're managing like the 405
but in multiple layers and and and the
pilots just have to trust what this
guy's seeing because
everything like if you're moving at 400
miles an hour the other person's moving
at 400 miles an hour no one's seeing
anything
my brother's an air traffic controller
and he uh loves it because he's at a
smaller airport so he just gets to kick
it nice
like no one's flying that day yeah not
that many every time i think about that
job i always it always reminds me of
breaking bad
yes like his daughter dies
and he comes back to work he goes back
to work and he makes a plane crash into
the neighborhood oh yeah no they hit
each other
oh and then the pieces yeah you're right
you're right so they don't have that
[ __ ]
green thing that goes beat like the
radar and the movies
beat and then you see the thing getting
closer beat and you're like oh no
i think that's the guy like on the
submarine where you're out of nowhere i
know right it's usually
cause it'll be like 50 dots yeah i know
i wonder what it's like like if you
don't have an air traffic controller
like what if you lose
communication for whatever reason i
think it's all digital now
[ __ ] i don't know i never asked them
because it's kind of boring
yeah it's so interesting because like we
are so dependent on
technology and i think they have so many
redundancies
so like if one channel i have another
one because i know with planes and stuff
too especially with planes
and cars have it too where every switch
has like
multiple switches in it so like it can't
just trigger by accident
because like i think um like when the
prius first came out
it's like you know how like the the
pedal was no longer directly connected
to the engine it was like to the
computer
and then to the end i don't even know so
when you give gas you're like telling
the computer to give gas
but then when the car first came out it
was just simply that right the it's
electronically doing that
but then there would be like um cosmic
waves that would hit it and all of a
sudden now your gas is stuck on forever
and people like a bunch of people died
so now yeah every single one of these
like
like controllers or switches whatever
have like multiple switches in it
so you're basically pressing three
switches at once so i assume with planes
there's like redundancies where
multiple things have to fail before like
you lose complete communication oh
that's good
that makes you feel better it's not like
a wright brothers archaic
a bicycle with a [ __ ] wing and [ __ ]
because don't they say that that's
what tends to happen around these like
certain pockets in
the earth like the bermuda triangle or
whatever there's like no
radio the signal like you lose all of it
some [ __ ] like that not the aliens
as soon as you go through the bermuda
triangle they go gotcha [ __ ]
and then they take you that's like their
venus flytrap
is that where what's her name
disappeared amelia yeah yeah a lot of
people yeah
but also you know she's a lady and she
was riding a plane
so that's that's women drivers is where
you're at
that's really dangerous yeah yeah she
had a male
co-pilot i guess oh well he was probably
trying to help
why wasn't he driving i thought she went
alone no she was by herself she was with
no she was with this guy oh really
yeah they both disappeared together oh i
never hear about this guy she had like a
i think he was a navigator or some [ __ ]
boy he [ __ ] up huh
you know what thank you you [ __ ] up
with the directions huh right i don't
know who did what but yeah
took her straight into the [ __ ] mouth
of the devil well she was the first
female aviator to fly solo across the
atlantic ocean but then what happened
when she disappeared let me see bermuda
triangle
if you were in this plane and then the
the the pilot just starts
giving you all these instructions
through the intercom would you start
freaking out
no i'd be filming out the window like
with them i'm not listening
but then how did he know that something
was gonna fly by
he didn't know i think he was just being
like i don't know he's like he's like
he's like i gotta get vlog content
because like i have to post today yeah
my stockpile is going away yeah like
algorithm will [ __ ] up seeing how steady
this
was and the the fact that it never it
wasn't shaking it didn't move
i'm thinking he stuck it to the window
oh like a suction
yeah that's what i'm guessing he had one
of these these mounts
oh [ __ ] he's like
because then he wouldn't be out the
window and he'd be like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy he didn't scream or
anything no there were a lot of people
i heard screaming but other people were
screaming but he was you remember that
one video
he's like somebody turned somebody
twigged out his play
dude i'd be [ __ ] flipping out
especially hearing the pilot
say brace brace like me watching the
video it like
gave me emotions where i'm like holy
[ __ ] this [ __ ] scary
have you been on a plane where it went
pretty much sideways like that and you
can see the ground
no holy [ __ ] not like that i've done
that
tilting buddy thing where they just yeah
a little bit of a tilt the scariest uh
thing i've had was a plane uh we were
going to beijing and they had like a icy
runway and like it was
storming and then um when we landed
it they didn't do it right so they had
to take off
and then do it again that was [ __ ]
like die hard
yeah it was like oh and then it was like
what the hell
so sorry everybody gotta try again
everyone was crying and [ __ ] man it was
crazy
like was it just like a little bit off
of the ground and then back down yeah it
was like
going down and then going back up it was
like yeah
damn did they say oh hey we found
we think we know what this was or well
no because i kept trying to find
more more info on this particular
incident
but like the airlines aren't really
saying anything and
yeah like i couldn't really find
anything else it was just that
people um they were reporting it like
the thankfully the pilot
did what he did and he was able to avoid
it but then they were saying that it was
like
pure like luck that he avoided that
yeah because like that thing like if
you're a pilot right and you're flying
towards it you see like a dot pretty
much
from the side we see like how long it is
so that's crazy that guy even had the
like
instincts to see something flying
towards him and he's like oh [ __ ] and he
like dips the plane
or traffic control could have been like
you have someone coming at you
at this speed yeah i mean but
if aliens are super smart he would know
to dodge that plane too
you would think their intelligent life
right you'd have to assume they said
what if we give them too much credit red
but there's probably women driver
yeah yeah yeah that has a male co-pilot
named fred noonan by the way oh so yeah
i was right yeah fred noonan
who's the navigator right uh so they got
locked together in bermuda triangle yeah
yeah that's on him dude people don't
blame him more they should it's on her
right don't even hear that it's on him
dude
yeah he she was probably flying all good
and he's like hey what do you want to
eat and she's like oh
[ __ ]
so why'd you open those worms that's
stupid
this is like anything and he goes all
right what about this no not that
you're so scared well no because
apparently the last thing that she
she said was that she would they were
lost so that's on him for sure
because he's a navigator really that was
the last thing she said that was like
the last thing that they reported is
like hey we're we're looking for
the their destination we haven't found
it yet basically yeah
one job yep yeah it was near new guinea
and then she's like fred and he's like
[Laughter]
yeah that was in 1937. damn that's great
there's a there's a photograph
i guess that came out a couple years
back where they had
i can't remember where it was but the
japanese military
have like um taking a picture
and in the background is a cat who looks
exactly like fred noonan
and there's a woman and her profile is
like
boom spot on amelia so is there
conspiracy there's a theory yeah that
that she
that they landed somewhere and then they
were captured by the japanese military
wow
pretty interesting but that'll be weird
why they didn't get released or anything
afterwards huh well there was beef back
then between
well there was world war ii yeah yeah so
that's that's
the running she's the last hammer
you